hello everyone and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong I'm here Jacqueline
Coley alongside my incredible co-host Mr
Mark Ellis and joining us again producer
Brian for our after dark episode we are
getting hi ladies and gentlemen
we know we're not we're sober as a judge
but it is 4 20. uh
Silver's a judge I know I like that one
I never knew judges to be like the
measure of sobriety I mean they should
be
ideally but I hope that it judges sober
yeah you always think of like I can't I
can't imagine Fred Gwen and my cousin
Vinnie taking a couple sips of Grandpa's
cough medicine when everybody else is at
recess
yeah but that's not that's
not that that would want you'd still
want them
to do they just the lawyers are busy
doing all the other stuff the judge just
says here he has to watch which is
literally one of the one times when
being awake yeah yeah staying awake and
paying attention that is a sober
person's Endeavor and we would know that
ladies and gentlemen because we are
about to recount 25 of our favorite
stoner movies ranked from
rottentomatoes.com next week is 4 20 the
Stoners holiday we also want to give you
guys 20 best movies to watch hi these
are both editorials that you guys can
check out over on the website which I
think is interesting with this list
because I actually do believe this list
has a little bit of both I feel this
business has everything about this list
pertains to weed in some way you will
see someone in here partaking in some
form of inebriation but stoner movies I
don't know the definition of a stoner
movie that's why I've included the
second list because I'm like would I
watch easy writer if I'm high legally
yeah yeah I don't know if I call it a
stoner movie or a movie that includes
people getting hot this is where
editorial comes into it see so we just I
think there's Alex Vo yes this is Alex
Vo because best he is the best actually
he really is the best because these
listicles the one thing I would tell you
I can't think of a single one of these
movies that would not be improved by
being high okay and I and I would also
say all of them have elements of high to
them I don't disagree with Easy Rider
the reason why I don't is because easy
writer defined a counterculture before
it was defined it was sort of like that
hippie generation and so you associate
with the hippie generation the peace and
the love and Woodstock and all that
stuff it's like people are having fun at
Woodstock stock there's some bad red
rope licorice going around in the crowd
to quote Wayne's World too mocking the
scares that they had at Woodstock but
like when I think of stoner movies it's
all that's my question it's like if I
just put the term stoner movie into your
head what is the first movie that comes
to mind for me it's actually Cheech and
Chong Up in Smoke and that's probably
not a coincidence because that was the
first time that I realized that I was
watching dudes who were getting high
constantly because we put that on in
high school and so they reminded me of
people I'd already seen on TV and movies
like they reminded me of because I'd
already seen Wayne's World by then and
I'd already been introduced characters
but it's all I mean a lot of that came
from Cheech and Chong and their comedy
their albums and then their movies and
so by the time I came to Up In Smoke I
was like I kind of knew what was going
on and it was hilarious to me so I
always look back on like Stoner move if
you're making a stoner movie you're sort
of speaking my language which even
though I didn't necessarily come to
partake in any of that stuff until I
needed help sleeping I always wondered
about your habits because I feel like
yeah in high school you're like the good
kid to do the drugs and the alcohol and
all that I never even drank in high
school I might have liked each of that
was based in anxiety I might have no
anxiety whatsoever
I mean like not wanting to be addicted
to something it had nothing to do with
the addiction it was more getting caught
that's why that was my paranoia not even
by my parents by my high school
basketball coach that's who I really
didn't want to get caught by
um and so we had that but then you also
compound that with the fact that like
you know it just it wasn't the addiction
thing it was also just like I was going
to be a professional athlete trackman I
got to treat my body right and then you
realize ah maybe it's not gonna happen
for you so I'm laughing five seven but
so yeah I'm five ten and a half you had
the focus of Michael Jordan with the
shot of Sam Bowie
the number two and three draft picks in
the 84 draft well done Jacqueline or
were you more Mel Turpin I'm sorry we
just saw air I wasn't even Melvin Turpin
yeah what wasn't even but I mean you
know you so so you come to this and it's
more from a comedic sensibility is why I
think I always appreciated stoner movies
because more often than not with the
exception of Easy Rider I might say on
this list every one of these is trying
to make you laugh it might be like Fear
and Loathing in Las Vegas and Easy Rider
are this are the two like the more
serious stoner movies where it's like oh
there's actual stuff going on we gotta
take seriously everything else is just a
fun Lark we're just doing this crazy
we're High we're stumbling around and
that's sort of the vibe that I think of
when I think of stoner movies well the
thing I would say to you is let me put
some editorial on you Brian this is this
is
this is what it is when we when when
Alex and granted if he was here and I
would honestly suggest him coming for
any one of our ranked episodes to do his
methodology when I was looking at this
list when you work here long enough you
can determine exactly what they're doing
this is not not you shouldn't think of
this as favorite movies for Stoners or
you should not even think of this as
favorite movies with Stoners in them
it's called favorite stoner movies
ranked what are your favorite stoner
movies rank in the sense of favorite
stoner movie representation okay that is
what they're actually trying to
accomplish with if you look at this list
what they're trying to show you are
various different types of Stoners so
that you can see different aspects of it
so you look at the easy writer this is
like the Counter Culture version of you
look at Dazed and Confused these are
Texas Stoners and really what you're
doing is you're getting a cross section
of the different types of Comedy comedic
ways that we can show Stoners on on
screen and if you look at it that way
things like inherent Vice we are the
Millers all make a lot more sense okay
yeah you got really heady for someone
who just wants to see Dazed and Confused
and just drop out no but if you really
look at it I get it every one of these
they just show a different version of
Stoner representation and that's why
they call it the 50 because the point of
this list is not for you to give a
definitive list that every stoner will
like that is what the other one is best
movies to watch High yeah this is
actually a list of the best
representations of Stoners that we've
seen in cinema throughout the years in
their score so that's why we get a wider
swaths
well sorry I would say Wayne's World is
like a good Stone like any kind of
Comedy that's silly and funny you just
that's a good movie to watch while
you're hot it's moving to watch while
high but you don't necessarily get the
drug culture and it's actually
purposefully removed from Wayne's World
and somebody like Alex I absolutely
think so Alex just so you know is a is a
whiteboard artist meaning like this is
what we used to do in the office is he
literally just sits there and when he
starts with this and he puts the title
of whatever the list is and he just
writes a long way it's hard and he's
like let me see what movies I love Yeah
and well no he just writes a list of
every stoner movie and then it's sort of
like Charlie day and that Always Sunny
episode where it's like all right like
let's let's hear the argument for this
one why does this one need to be on the
list
this is like Alex works at Nike and he's
like which which do which athlete do we
want to represent yes wearing our shoe
so you're looking at all these and
you're like okay that's my number one
pick that's my number two yeah that's my
number three and so you really do do it
that way but it is about this has to be
defended to be on the list first and
then you rank them in order but it's the
you have to make sure that it earns a
spot first I would love to hear that
conversation of like do we include scary
movies well if you worked and never went
over to the editorial there's nobody in
the office right now and everyone's
working for a moment in pajamas right
now no but we used to we literally used
to have these editorial meetings and now
we just do them more versions
now we send them those lists we send
them uh via Google like our version of
Google it's all virtual but it's the
same thing be like all right Alex I'm
working on this list give me your votes
for this we literally just did this the
other day with the 25 we're doing I'm
doing a list of the 25 best quotes sorry
25 best speeches from Oscars for the
past 25 years so I'm going to come up
with the list and then guess what we are
editorial people then put ours together
and then we defend it and so yeah no
offense guys y'all are getting uh in
system in family Squad League before we
started the podcast bro I was like I
don't even know what editorial does here
and I'm like I thought you just showed
up through the podcast
if anybody is qualified to talk about
the list of stoner movies it'd be me
because while everybody else that works
here is on slack I just kind of made the
excuse that every time I hear this
I just get this fever dream trigger it
sounds like the Predator to me is like
stalking me so I actually do just sit at
home because I work at night and my call
my comedian culture is very closely
linked to Stoner culture in that you
know we're just kind of hanging out all
day don't really do anything and then
you're goofy on stage you come up with
jokes that's what I think of when I
think of stoner movies but that's not
necessarily Fair because that's what
stoner comedies may be yes but there's
other movies however if you're gonna
talk about movies that you want to watch
high I would look at the list of the
stoner movies ranked and say get
inherent Vice as far away yeah that is
not a good trip to be fair that's me
sober or high yeah or drunk or any other
state of mind I just I could not stand
that movie and the other thing that told
me that too was when I was looking at
this I was like where is clerks but it's
like he specifically chose Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back as the best
representation of the Stoners of the
stoner versions of honestly I would say
Silent Bob and Jay are two of the most
famous donors in cinema of all the
movies they've been in that is the most
stoner movie that is the biggest like
they have blunt man in that one you know
what I mean yeah
so again yeah not just to bring the
point home one more time that's how you
put some editorial on them
I'm just very heavy again for I just
want to get high and giggle
the other list is for you best movies to
watch hi we have a list for everyone
Brian is not just the one okay what are
we going to disseminate first here what
do you want to talk about yes all right
like this is the one I was gonna say
we'll start with the 25 movies ranked
okay I would say we'll go down the list
but it's a pretty exhaustive list I'll
let you all pick one one what to talk
about first that you think I'll give you
this one what is your favorite pick on
here and then which one would you kick
out you already kicked out in here I was
at 25 and I am kicking out in hair
advice so you're kicking out in hair
advice which one are you kicking out and
then I'll give you the ones that you're
like this is the top dog I would kick
that out too and because I love Dazed
and Confused and I love this is the end
but they're very different movies like
this is the end I'm dying laughing just
very funny nonsense yeah so funny Dazed
and Confused is just a Vibe it's a
hangout movie yeah you're just hanging
out there's some funny moments
it's the hangout Stoner representation I
get it but I guess it depends on your
personality as a stoner Fair like what
do you connect to I connect to more of
Seth Rogen like doing the Backstreet
Boys dance at the end of the movie Fair
okay dying and Danny McBride okay so
you'll kick out probably I inherent Vice
is there any other one that you would
kick out because I have other ones I
would kick out I mean for Madness
by the way this is a representation of
the Gob propaganda yeah I haven't seen
it but I just can't imagine oh no it's
it's a dream yes the one that I would
kick out is we are the Millers because I
feel that one is the one that is most
tangentially not attached to that
because the the stoner we're
representing is the stoner scammer I
understand that that's who Jason
Sudeikis plays is the like basically
based on drugs yeah the plot involves
weeds
and he's a drug addict in it like he's a
complete stoner yeah yeah he's like a
stoner dude like not Stoner like uh very
Peter Parker in into the spider-verse
from from the Jake Johnson University
that's what he is you know this is the
guy that does not have his crap together
he is just smoking weed and making
mistakes and showing why he probably
grew up in a broken home that's what he
is in this movie and so I just don't I
don't feel that when that that one does
not doesn't connect with you it doesn't
connect with me
um and and like I I do it also I will
say Cheech and Jog ended up here twice
with good reason they deserve to be here
twice they have two movies but if you
know nice dreams compared to Up In Smoke
it is literally like two different
movies the first one was their big
Studio Movie well not shouldn't say
Studio Movie their most production value
version of what they were doing nice
dreams is a fantasy movie it's like
Disney duck remember that Daffy Duck
Treasure Island cartoon where they just
do all kinds of crazy stuff it's like a
compilation movie and so I really do
defend this list for the carefulness of
it yeah so it's much tougher for me
because I see in hair advice I'm like
that's the one that's off even though
there's other movies that are tougher
watches for me but just because again
this list isn't the movies that we want
to watch necessarily this is the movies
that we feel need to be considered the
essentials all different like like parts
and other areas and corners of Stoner
culture yeah so I'm looking at
everything else feels like it it at
least has earned a place in here scary
movie to me feels more like a film that
I would want to watch High yeah versus
something that's like you know that I
would put in the National Archives as
this needs to be known as a stoner move
it doesn't there's scenes of of
consumption or comedy yeah Stoner horror
comedy is what it's trying to do is
there another one on here that even
remotely gets near the horror comedies
place maybe horror and and weed should
go hand to hand more than I mean the
Leprechaun movie Black in the hood has
it
um yeah yeah when he gets the yeah right
Leprechaun in the Hood a Leprechaun in
the Hood he gets they get him high yeah
and he has like a whole like PCP moment
yeah I don't know sure yeah yeah like a
get out like that's a not stoner
that is actually one of those I have
weird movies that I watch high like
movies that somebody else wouldn't watch
high but I would watch get out high I
would also watch I would also watch
Midsummer High even though I hate that
movie because that's the movie to watch
high so you can laugh at this
Ridiculousness giggle with some of the
stuff yeah I'm saying I do need to point
this out uh because one of our fans are
gonna do it if I don't
um I actually was in a stoner horror
movie
what great premise no look that up right
now yeah it's type it in I'll say it
once if you need to you know barp it out
then and again this is probably why the
movie wasn't all that successful the
name of the film was little
and you're I literally forgot about it
until you mentioned leprechaun they get
the Leprechaun high so the premise of of
little effort is I plant exterminator
with Lloyd yeah I played Lloyd and Chuck
was played by a a brilliant actor named
Max and um and so it's me and Max
mullion and we are these two
exterminators and we're cleaning out
this like house and uh there's or an
abandoned warehouse or something and we
find this creature with kind of like an
Ewok and it's like super menacing but
we're Stoners and we found out that if
we give if we get this thing High then
it's just like a really fun kind of hang
but when the weed runs out that's when
it gets ornery and starts killing people
so we bring little effort to a Halloween
party and the weed runs out and so
little effort doesn't have any more weed
to keep him pacified so he just starts
murdering everybody and we gotta stop
little effort before he kills every last
person to the party jeez we're stopping
by just giving him more weed and uh yeah
and that was pretty much how the
production was run too
I probably don't anymore
um but it's it I don't know if it's
available anywhere the trailer is still
on YouTube she can still watch the
trailer for I think they changed it they
like 10 years later they finally
realized that maybe the name little
effort isn't the best not to Market to
Market so they changed it to something
else I can't remember what it was but um
you know this is just when I was doing a
lot of like commercials and it's like
yeah sure I'll do a feature film the
whole thing shot at this like abandoned
warehouse in Pasadena for for two weeks
wow but but it was a stoner hard comedy
and that is where my brain went not
because I'm trying to Champion myself
but because I'm trying to think there's
very little Stoner horror movies yeah
that you get yeah nothing I can think of
so it's basically there's a few like
like any of the the horror comedies may
have like Stoner aspects to them like
there's always the one Stoner dude
that's gonna die so like there's that
like a Freddy movie or a Jason movie
there's going to be that one teenager
that's like really interesting but no to
your point I think that's also partially
why we have this entry on the list like
let's get scary movie yeah like I feel
like that's that that's the reason why
it's out there
um I will also add to the one that I
love the best on this list and it
wouldn't be one that I think other
people would appreciate it but that's
Super Troopers because I feel like Super
Trooper hits
so many of it it's a straight comedy
which is just fun to be high in addition
to that it had this cult-like Statics
where so much of it was like subversive
and underground and it just it never
felt like adults were doing this movie
in every aspect of it um was was a part
of that and it showed I think these
really hilarious Stoners and that they
were cop Stoners in this case I mean you
know what I mean like Brian Cox isn't he
yeah like great great actors being silly
Broken Lizard stuff like yeah yeah I
appreciate all of it and and that was
also very similar to a lot of these guys
in here some of these guys manage to
sneak in really respected actors into
their movies of these like uh ridiculous
settings uh well The Big Lebowski yeah
just Bridges but more important than
that Soul Plane with uh Snoop Dogg Snoop
Dogg and that one but like just the weed
brings people together Half Baked had
like half of Hollywood that's what I was
trying to find Half Baked where it was
like all of these cameos show up for
that why have you brought up halfway
because that's another movie that I
think it might be the most stoner movie
of anything on this list other than
Cheech and Chong maybe but because it's
it's so funny but it also that is what
it's about and it's about just dealing
with life while you're super high yeah
all the time whether you're going on a
date or whether you're just sitting on
the couch like there's so many great
laughs in Half Baked but it is a great
stoner movie oh yeah and like you said
cameos Bob Saget has a great Cameo Saget
has an amazing
amazing comedy in that one it's actually
really funny what's crazy now about a
lot of these movies that I even thought
of it when we were doing Super Mario
Brothers we were talking about Bob
Hopkins Bob Hodgkins and Dennis Hopper
it's the Hodgkin's Hopper like it's
Hoskins
I'm saying Hodgkins like lymphoma yeah
say it again
Hoskins
Hopper it's Hoskins and Hopkins is
what's getting you yes
that's what I'm saying like and again we
want to reiterate to Legal we did not
get no no totally sober is a judge
seriously Bob and Dennis they're both
gone uh Bob's gone like so many of these
movies that we recount them now we talk
about these people as so present because
these performances those like think
about Bob Saget in that movie and just
how hilarious is in this line read you
cannot think of that person as not alive
vibrant in that moment but he is
unfortunately lost us in a couple of
these movies have similar names already
you could you could make a list that's a
lot longer than 25 movies or 20 movies
about movies that get better when you
might be oh yeah yeah Super Mario
Brothers I might put it from 93 if I put
at the top of that list I will say it's
so funny again not this is actually not
me giving you business anymore about
editorial but it is true about the
editorial team everybody has their areas
of expertise and Alex is really good
with like animation Debbie obviously
knows TV but more importantly she's
really great with I think uh underground
sci-fi like TV shows like she's a bit
Trekkie or whatever Ryan knows a lot
about I would say like really small more
like Independent films like similar to
me and everybody has their things but I
am definitely known for is it thirsty
like it was just thirsty and not thirsty
like porn thirsty like Cinemax thirsty
like Outlander thirsty like 365 days
thirsty in the sense of like if people
are going to entertainment you know
Basic Instinct stuff that's gonna make
them feel entertained but also really
sexy I'm the person that will call those
balls and Strikes but the other thing is
which things are good for the for the
stoner crowd like which content I am the
person I'm not saying this is because of
anything that I am hmm not at all my
father listens to this podcast hey Dad
uh my stepdad whatever he knows weed is
legal uh well I was gonna say for your
top 10 movies of last year you included
jackass forever I did and the jackass
series you get high you get drunk you
watch those movies you die last night
yeah yeah I would say I would have put
jackass on here if it wasn't clearly
that these are narrative features as
opposed to that's more I you know live
action whatever documentary or whatever
yeah but they are Stoner representation
they're aged Stoners totally they're all
age these are the guys that used to be
listening to like black flag and they
were really punk rock and they've aged
into it now this is for the day of girl
crowd okay yeah which is which is sort
of cropped up as you get older because I
do appreciate the things certain aspects
of your Youth and that's sort of what
that's another reason why jackass
forever such a beautiful movie Goonies
and Stoners Never Say Die Goonies and
Stoners never give up yeah I mean look
it's it's got some medical benefits but
you know yeah that's why we do it if you
talk about the the best movies to watch
high now so if you move over to the
other list like the 20 best movies to
watch High I actually think that's a
much tougher job to do to just narrow
that down to 20. yeah well there is oh
sorry that's more personal taste yeah
whereas with the 25 best stoner movies
like what Jacqueline said it's like
let's get some representation let's make
sure that there's a horror movie in
there let's make sure that there's
dramatic stuff and then there's a lot of
comedies too and different types of
comedies like Friday is a very different
comedy than say Dave's confused which is
very different comedy than say scary
movie three so but the movies to watch
high that can run the gamut
one thing I would ask you now now that
you've heard my deep ethos on the first
list now that you've looked at this list
the the best movies to watch hi what's
hi I think I have also discerned some of
the ethos to this because yeah it says
it in the title but I think we think
there's like an extra layer to it what
do you think was the most sort of like
what do you think how do you think they
Define the parameters of it because I
think I I kind of well now it makes
sense when you guys get together in your
little tribes and you just uh happening
on the Whiteboard you're like does Tron
legacy belong on there does the Pink
Floyd most of this is just in Alex's
brain now like it's not like I could see
like this is just very representative of
Alex and his Knights at home maybe maybe
but like yeah I can see why the Matrix
is in there or Pulp Fiction or whatever
but like like something like Logan's Run
just like a heady kind of sci-fi like
that's not on the list but I would put
Logan's Run on there because that movie
messes with me man and I can always why
I want to get deeper into this why does
Logan's Run mess with you because you
said really do you know the premise of
it yeah they die at age 30. yeah and
they go to sanctuary and they all get
lifted up like oh we're gonna be like
like saved and go to sanctuary and they
just die in front of everybody and it's
just it's a wild movie I wish they
remade it and did it amazingly
remake it was like a TV show too
Nicholas wending refin was supposed to
do with Ryan Gosling but that was the TV
show was that one yeah yeah so Gosling
just did Blade Runner 2049 yeah it's
kind of the same another companion like
the way that got received probably
turned them off for me that could have
been it you're doing Barbie now
[Music]
yeah speaking of Coen brothers movies
like because we have The Big Lebowski on
the other list but a serious man does
anyone know that movie oh yeah I love
that move too and that's another one
that's like oh my God I'm like losing my
mind like watching it so I think his
Logic for this one is I think all of
these movies play better slash different
if you are high watching yeah so I don't
think it's necessarily that these are
movies that if you're high the visuals
or subject matter will particularly
affect you I think it's more if you are
in inebriated State the enjoyment factor
for this movie can be appreciated on a
level that you cannot appreciate if you
are sober does that make sense yes but
it's very confusing that like inceptions
on here along with Tropic Thunder that's
why this is a beautiful words that's
what I would say yeah so I would tell
you that I think that makes sense the
absurdity of Tropic Thunder and like
just this idea of them not getting where
they are yeah when you are stoned is way
more hilarious than if you're just
because honestly it's like it's more of
like a workplace comedy right when you
aren't sewn but when you make a movie
but when you're stoned you're like
literally looking at this on like the
other level so actually no I do I do I
think Step Brothers if you're stoned
when you're watching it you can see your
own level of
step brotherness in yourself as you're
watching it
I'm pieces and here we are just together
in this box
I know you're coming off Mike I'm not
all right yeah it's just now I got a
coffee but Step Brothers does hit
different because of the one line the
one-liners of just like yeah why are you
so sweaty I was watching cops and that
just hits like imagine a guy sweating
while he's watching cops it's so funny
that's why I love this list is because I
feel like this list is either just
hilarious comedies that are gonna get
funnier if you're high or it's sort of
like that mind expansion yes which is
what you would get with Tron legacy with
the fall with Pink Floyd uh the wall
maybe even The Fifth Element in there a
little bit too but definitely definitely
The Matrix in 2001 like if you get
higher you're not suddenly giggling at
2001 A Space Odyssey but it also is
going to make you maybe think about the
movie differently yeah um so under
proper supervision of course look being
stoned is a state of depressed
um relaxation like basically sensory
issues things that would normally bother
you don't bother you in as much that's
because you're in your open and open to
stimulus yes positive stimulus or
negative stimulus just basically just
open you up to that and so like I get it
I get I get why it can be Pink Floyd The
Wall or something like Spirited Away
where maybe you just want to watch or
2001 you just want to watch those with
the sound off and just geek out with the
visuals literally but I the ending of
2001 was just like lights just flashing
in your face yeah I would lose my mind
but I also could really appreciate shot
of the Dead like yeah that airplane film
or Grand Budapest Hotel the delivery of
the lines in Grand Buddha pest hotel
that sort of like Earnest
um absurdity that he employs yeah that's
hilarious that's great yeah but like
when I was a kid I thought that even
before I saw like Cheech and Chong I
realized kind of like what they were
doing yeah why they acted the way they
did when I was a kid I thought like
something like 2001 and was a stoner
movie to me because I'm like oh that's
just like like adults just get high and
just like kind of stare at this you
didn't really understand all even Pink
Floyd The Wall like like my friends
watched that a lot in high school and
they now that I look back they probably
were getting and I just like wasn't
aware of it that was that stupid but
you're like oh they're watching this on
a totally different wavelength than I am
and so it's so funny to see that on a
list with something like Step Brothers
which will make me laugh sober or high
yeah but there's times now when I am
relaxing with my herbal medication I
uncontrollably laugh at stuff it is
funny yeah but if I'm it it really does
like I'm slapping my knee sober I'm on
the floor if I had my gummy yeah well
Family Guy does that a lot oh yeah yeah
well growing up because you weren't like
in the culture or like smoking at all
could you appreciate like a stoner
comedy like a pineapple well no I I
could I could have appreciated the
pineapple expresses of the world yeah
because is I met folks like Wayne and
Garth and Paulie Shore and Encino Man so
you understood characters were sort of
the gateways too why are these guys
acting like that like I intrinsically
understood that Wayne and Garth and
Cheech and Chong are cool but I didn't
necessarily understand why I was like
it's because they're not really like
like doing what Society tells them to do
at that age like what is it about it and
then that's sort of your entry point and
so when you are looking at people and
you're a kid and you say oh that's a
cool person you're naturally going to
gravitate towards that you know and so
whether you know why they're cool or not
you just know that everybody seems to
like them again they're they're getting
laughs people want to watch their movies
so it's like or like a McConaughey and
Dazed and Confused like why is everyone
loving this is so cool he's creep when
you watch it yeah when you watch it back
but yeah he's just he's cool yeah like
why why is he like that even if you
can't quite wrap your head around it
yeah I think it's just the absence of
anger in people that are normally very
angry
average CIS white dude in the 70s was
just very angry so anyone walking around
that was just like what's up man
unicorn yeah I think the only way I
would look at it is whatever these these
stoner movies what you want to say stone
or whatever is Stoners used to be coded
like back when it was uh The Many Loves
of Dobie Gillis uh it wasn't that Bob
Denver was a stoner Gilligan was not a
stoner explicitly but like if you look
back on it that's what he is he's coded
to be an actual Stoner people like um
not Cheech and Chong but Wayne and Garf
were also coded to be Stoners because
they started on SNL when they couldn't
explicitly say that they were why were
they in the basement doing this public
radio show with their guitars it's not
like they were stoned out of their minds
anyone from your okay like for instance
the Ninja Turtles yeah Michelangelo
they're all coated yeah high all the
time they all are it's just Raphael's
the more responsible one but they're
also sorry I'm sorry Leonardo that's
right sorry yeah Raphael is not those
and we've talked I know I'm sorry he's a
locker room cancer get him off the
turtles all he does is cause trouble for
the other Turtles what's his weapon
that's the size we know why you look
cool yeah do you know the do you know
the okay he's basically has tuning Forks
as a weapon yeah you know what I'm gonna
give y'all I'm gonna give you this thing
so the turtles are actually given
weapons to fit their personality the
reason why Raphael is given the size
because the Sigh is protective
instrument and it's actually not meant
to attack
of the team he needs therapy
Michelangelo has numb chucks because
nunchucks require intense concentration
and he's a bit of a scatter brain and so
he gave him a weapon that would make him
Focus Master Splinter by the way Master
Splinter might have been the biggest
donor of course exactly
yeah train them in martial arts the guy
that does the Baton is the most
technological one because he was the
most basic and it was the most basic and
I wanted to keep him grounded to realize
even though you're very smart you should
stay grounded and then Leonardo Leonardo
is the leader with katana and he is
actually the most conscientious and the
most likely to protect his brothers so
that's why he's got the Lethal Weapon
and that's why he has the lethal weapons
you've thought about this my mind no
this is literally like part of the like
I mean they were named after
philosophical painter yeah they were
named Renaissance painters and those
guys were not just guys that painted
they were guys you literally opened my
mind you gotta rewatch again I've I've
known as the turtles my whole life I
just never thought of it like that no
shade to Raphael yeah he is antagonistic
because even in a family you need
somebody to be the black sheep because
they're the ones that say
right right now dude you know speaking
of Rotten Tomatoes an incredible
editorial staff that's an article I want
to see Jack I want to see Jaclyn's
articles
again this is what we do over here
that's just what we do it but no look
let's get back to this because whatever
the I will say I'm a little Jaded by
this if you the two things that Rotten
Tomatoes you will get very quick with
learning how to defend a score and a
guide because there will always be
people I feel like us and the people
that watch Mojo know it's up the minute
you put a parameter on a list you'll
have somebody coming for you being like
f that that's partially why we make them
um but there's um one thing I will say
about all these we have a new series now
called The Essentials which is where we
we really try to get to the essential of
a genre and I do feel like to Brian's
point to like sort of back him up what
are you saying I think when that was
made it was before we leaned into the
essentials branding and I think that is
a more accurate description of our five
favorite Stoners when I host the the
essentials vids yeah you're counting
down like let's say it's the 10 best I
just just for a second argument the 10
best stoner movies at the end what what
our disclaimer always is it's like now
keep in mind this is just some we don't
have time to get to all the great stoner
movies so comment and let us know what
yours and we encourage people to do that
listen or watching the show today let us
know what your favorite stoner movies
are that maybe we didn't highlight what
I think would be a fun little exercise
again because I come from a sports
mentality too is you want to do a quick
Fantasy Draft of like our top three so
like we're all gonna take we're all
gonna have our first second and third
round draft pick of the best movies to
watch high but if I take one then it's
off the table and y'all can't take it oh
okay so we'll start with Jacqueline
Jaclyn gets the first round pick so what
movie on the 20 best movies to watch
high are you taking at number one who is
your Hakeem Olajuwon the one movie that
you need out of the first round 20
movies wow probably Fifth Element Fifth
Element is off the board for JC okay
Brian you're up next I go comedies I'm
going 21 Jump Street that'll just keep
me me just cracking up I have a feeling
we're not going to have a lot of
cross-pollination 21 Jump Street is off
the board for me my first movie again I
think Monty Python the Holy Grail is the
funniest movie ever made but I am not
taking that as my stoner movie I'm
probably gonna go with
um I'm Gonna Take Fight Club I think
Fight Club why is that a stoner movie
why is that a like he literally has an
imaginary friend the entire does okay
does have an imaginary friend the entire
time so I you know I I might I might
imbibe a little bit like it's weird
like you're like how is this a stoner
movie you know we're not being editorial
you're posing a lot of editorial type
questions
all right in true snake drought fashion
I get to go again because I picked the
last in the first round so my next pick
I'm gonna go with Step Brothers yeah
yeah I want to giggle okay Ryan you're
up ooh I'll go Grand Budapest because
yeah it's just got that dry sense of
humor I'm not gonna to miss you taking
that off the board nowhere near my top
picks so I don't doubt that yeah you
know I kind
of things on here that's the problem
I know and then we'll get to your
all-time favorite movie to watch it's
not that it's just I'm not in love with
these I would say that's why the weed is
yeah
I would say if I had to pick another one
I'll pick airplane if you make me pick
another one off this list because I
won't pick Monty Python because that's
what Mark is I'm gonna have a hard time
because honestly I like all of these
movies none of them are ones that I'm
like oh yeah if I'm watching this the
next time I'm watching it I want to be
stoned in fact a couple movies on our
previous list for sure but not this one
yeah all right so Jacqueline is
absconding her final pick No I gave it
to you no that was your second pick now
you get to give us your third pick oh I
have a snake draft did I get my second
yeah was my second he didn't do a second
yes he did well he's been 21 Jump Street
and he did uh didn't you take something
yeah oh okay I picked so boring nobody
even acknowledged that it happened facts
um Spirited Away okay okay nice horse
movie I would say that that is not a
movie to be you know that's number one
you could be you could be stoned
but the type of stoned is dependent on
how advanced in that problems you are
I would say you might need more
complicated stoning for that one but
true has Shaun of the Dead been taken no
it's all yours I'll take Sean of the day
that's a good stoner movie yeah I think
I am going to go yeah I'm between 2001
uh Fantastic Planet and the Matrix for
my final one
um Tron legacy I just I I can't stand
Tron for one simple reason and I've made
the point on the show before it's a I I
hate when somebody who's literally never
heard or or played this sport before
gets into this world and immediately
becomes the LeBron of it like yeah he's
just the all of a sudden he turns into
Michael Vick on a football field he's
literally never played this he didn't
stretch
this is where the failed athlete in you
shows yeah
and this guy just comes on the
like the little girl in me yeah like
that little failed athlete is in there
somewhere I think the word failed is a
Little Bit Hurts I don't want to say
failed athlete the amateur the amateur
Superstar the failed athletes I was like
I just missed the free throws to win the
big game you know why
your anger that is your anger of being
like you know what I knew where I was in
this I was I was I was here I did the
best that I could and I played for as
long as I can the idea that some man
could just be this good at anything like
as if they could teleport somebody in
here to do the same thing it would make
you mad me and Garrett Headland on a
Tron Court together and I think I could
take him that's my video game though
weren't you good at Tetris right away
you didn't have to spend a thousand
Tetris right away so again that's the
point I still had to work at it by the
way you and I me watching American Idol
I'm just the same bitter Betty do not
think I'm saying this to try and make
you feel worse are you kidding me
watching musical theater be like if I
had love and acceptance at 16 I would be
on Broadway
I am resentful I could have been a
contender and so yeah the failed
performer in me is amateur
I'm going I'm going 2001. I I because I
actually want to do that you haven't
seen it well if you haven't seen it
while uh partaking so I might actually
and I might actually want to do that
like maybe bring a gummy into a theater
next time they because 2001 makes the
theater rounds every so often I've never
seen it on the big screen yeah so that's
like an ArcLight reopening kind of thing
yeah it is an ARCA light reopening man
did you guys see by the way I did see
friend uh the Simon Thompson who's a
he's a great movie pundit uh we should
have on the show at some point he was
walking by the ArcLight in Hollywood was
a casualty of the pandemic and um it was
very windy here in La the last uh the
last week so some of the boards that
were up on Arc Light got knocked off by
the wind and he took a picture looking
into the vast expansive lobby of the
ArcLight and it just it looked like a
haunted house that's weird oh wow yeah
it kind of looks like a girl it looks
like Crimson Peak or something like it
was just like it like like wasn't like
it you knew the board like that famous
board that showed all the movies and it
was just not lit up at all it's just
weird it just hasn't been I mean what's
really funny though is like they have to
figure it out because that's a
historical Monument like so they can't
get rid of it so whatever happens there
has to be a theater so somebody's
probably trying to make it into
something bigger that can make more
money than what it is for what it is so
like they're like oh we'll make a
theater but we want to build condos on
top of it right and so that's probably
why it's closed they're not just gonna
open the Dome again no because that
doesn't make any money because that's
already a failed business and they're
like we're not gonna change it and
whenever they do come back I think they
will
you got to make the popcorn better oh
popcorn I'm not I'm not gonna let any
popcorn at the Arc Light you lived here
first and then the track up the three
flights to stay the corn itself wasn't
great and then the butter topping was
gross my thing is is I just want like
Alamo to buy it and then do that just
make it like I don't want to do that you
know what I mean like I just want like
another so the thing I would tell you is
um Alamo is still my my theater and I
like what they do I did not have the
emotional attachment to the arcolate
that all you do the archolite was the
theater that I went to I didn't I just
knew I I had a reverence for it I guess
I think it's more of like the Tarantino
generation of the 70s and 80s who like
love that but for us I mean Hollywood's
impossible to get to yeah
I have an emotional and not just because
QT owns it but I have an emotional
attachment to the New Beverly new bevel
he's like stepping back into time I even
have an emotional attachment to even
something like the Vista to a certain
extent you know what I mean by the way
and I've and I've had the pleasure
telling QT this to his face the popcorn
at New Beverly is facts fantastic corn
and is by far the cheapest corn you can
get no way it's like three dollars for a
large whoa it's great great corn so I
would say that you want when you're
stoned of course yeah so I don't have
the emotional attachment but it's still
a great theater I do hope it comes back
because whatever we are all beholden to
this industry we wanted to stay alive so
go see a movie kids hopefully a stoner
one but if you do go Stone don't look on
your phone bring your phone away it's
not gonna help you it does not give you
an excuse to be rude if you're drunk it
and it's just as dangerous it with
holding your phone you're just as as
much of a danger when you're drunk as
you are when you're high get get the
technology away from you yeah the only
technology you need is a movie theater
projector operated by somebody else yes
what's your what's your top movie did
you say your top stoner movie like move
a movie that you just put an all-time
doesn't have to be on the list yeah it
doesn't have to be on the list mine
might be biodome is it you get high you
watch that you crack up that's great and
it's better High yeah yeah that's what
the Encino mans and the son-in-laws were
leading up to
as far as like the movie I want to watch
when I'm hot like that that one okay
okay all right and yours is Brian well
Logan not Logan's room a serious man by
the Coen brothers that's a different
kind of watching high but just to giggle
and laugh
Step Brothers pretty high separate I
liked Pineapple Express more I'm gonna
go Pineapple Express because the ending
scene where they're just like Diner
riffing and just like you died for a
second right he's like yeah I think I
did sign or Danny McBride was laughing
we could barely move his neck kills me
Danny McBride just oozes just funny like
he can just sit there and be funny
especially and this is the end and
anything he's in he's bounded down I
watched high enough dude this is my mind
I would say for me on this one it would
the only other thing I would add is um
if you were able to do what we call the
more advanced stoner movies you know
what I mean when I say this uh if it was
that I would say Fear and Loathing in
Las Vegas oh boy you need to watch it
did not finish that if you are again
this is not for the beginners this is
Advanced lessons but if you're in the
advanced lesson stage of stoner movies
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas I'll know
what's up I'm not taking Dr Coley's
class I I'm out that's it for us uh
there's 200 movies after dark Brian's
sir good to see you from outside of the
desk Mark always a pleasure sir and it's
good to talk stoner movies with you now
that you're no longer tea totaler yeah I
know this is fun I'm in man I'm in once
you reach failed athlete level you just
get into the drugs you can't get in
trouble for shading a guy that graduated
high school 20 years ago like this kid
but I will say both my athletic career
and especially my matriculation with
this particular uh substance are
highlighted in my new special which I
think as of this recording is going to
be out within a month's time
I talk about the pandemic everybody got
a hobby mine happened to be something
related to the show we're talking
so you can check that out should be
everywhere in about a month so total
live and well look for it alive and well
that that is two words that are hard to
put together these days ladies and
gentlemen it's like Hoskins and Hopper I
know I want to remind everyone if you
have after darts suggestions please let
us know this is our new fun sort of like
experiment I'm going to be taking slight
vacation for a while but
RT is wrong at Rotten tomatoes.com look
you guys have been through this before I
normally disappear this time of year
after award season just to find peace
and some centering this year I'll be
having surgery so I'll be gone a little
bit longer but I will be back that's
gonna do it for us this week week for
Mark Ellis myself producer and star of
this episode Mr Brian Perez web thank
you all for watching and we'll see y'all
next week bye excellent Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]